من النادر أن نرى كونغرسًا موحدًا
يرى الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين متحدين في
إدانتهم ، فقط ما مدى
قلقك من تأثير
ما حدث مؤخرًا على البلد
ومتابعته هو ولي العهد الأمير محمد
بن سلمان في خطر بأي شكل من الأشكال.  من
موقفه من موضوع الكونجرس
نواجه نفس القضية بعد
11 سبتمبر تمكنا من تجاوز هذا
الوضع بسبب هويتنا لأن
الناس يكتشفون أننا صامدون
فنحن لسنا الشيطان
المتجسد بل بالأحرى لدينا  لدينا
مساهمات إيجابية للغاية
نقدمها للعالم وبالطبع سألت
عن مكانة ولي العهد
وفي المملكة يوجد ولي العهد
لأن الملك اختاره
وليًا للعهد ولأن
مجلس العمدة  أيد مجلس الخلافة في
المملكة العربية السعودية
اختياره وليا للعهد ولأن
الناس أحبه ، وإذا اتخذت
قدرا من الرأي العام في المملكة
العربية السعودية اليوم ،  هنا
يقف ولي العهد على الأرجح أعلى بكثير مما
كان عليه قبل ستة أشهر ليس بسبب
قتل ياماجا شوجي ،
لكنهم يرونه في الأساس
شخصًا يقود المملكة أو ظل يوجهها بثبات
نحو التنمية والتعامل
مع البقية.  من العالم